I gotta tell you we got a we got an okay
show for you tonight so whoa whoa whoa
okay I'm sorry is there a is there
problem yes there's a problem did you
just say we've got an okay show not a
fantastic show or an unbelievable and
life-changing show yeah it's it's an
okay show what's wrong with that
well I for one did not walk here all the
way from Chesterfield Ohio wait wait
wait a minute wait a minute you walked
to Los Angeles from Ohio that's what you
did sir
let me finish I did not walk all the way
from Ohio then somewhere outside Boulder
Colorado realized I left my Conan
tickets at home then turn around and
walk back to Ohio then walk to your
studio all over again a trip that took
over six weeks and cost me my position
as chief of surgery at a very
prestigious horse hospital I did not do
all of this just to see an okay show and
I don't think any of these fine people
did either
you're jerks I don't think anyone else
here walked across half the country to
attend a taping of a TV show idea I dug
a tunnel here from Nova Scotia that was
really not necessary let me ask you this
would you have your toupee clean by an
OK to pay cleaner I don't wear it you
pay that's your own hair Wow okay I
guess that's a choice all right how
about this
would you get a root canal from an okay
dentist probably not and I guess you'd
be fine subscribing to an okay wireless
network wait a minute what did you just
say to me which part I said a bunch of
stuff don't ever ever accuse me of
settling for an okay wireless network I
would rather eat sushi off the floor of
a bowling alley then use a wireless
network that's just okay I need to know
I'm using the best wireless network and
that's exactly why I use AT&T hey that
could be an ad for AT&T oh it is
you